Aquí tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones
"3t" más "4g" igual a 6 y "-6t" más "g" igual a 6.
Hay un montón de maneras para resolver sistemas
de ecuaciones, puedes graficarlos,
puedes resolver por sustitución, pero cuando ves
los coeficientes en algunos de los términos
en este caso los coeficientes de las "t",
casi se pueden cancelar y digo casi
pues si sumas "3t" menos "6t" no se van a cancelar,
no va a desaparecer la "t",
pero si multiplico la primera ecuación por 2,
para obtener "6t",
entonces si,
cuando sumemos las dos ecuaciones,
se va a cancelar la "t" y solo quedará la "g",
pero recuerda,
no se vale que tan solo multiplique "3t" por 2,
lo que hago del lado izquierdo,
lo tengo que hacer del lado derecho,
de esa manera garantizo que no se altera la
ecuación, además,
tengo que hacerlo a todo el lado izquierdo,
así es que vamos a hacerlo.
Vamos a multiplicar toda la ecuación por 2.
Tenemos entonces 2 por "3t" más "4g"
es igual a 2 por 6, todo lo que haga de un lado,
lo tengo que hacer del otro lado, nos queda entonces
2 por "3t" = "6t" más 2 por "4g" es "8g"
y esto es igual a 2 por 6 = 12,
en realidad he escrito la misma restricción,
la misma información que teníamos aquí
multiplicada por 2.
Ahora, déjame escribir la segunda ecuación justo abajo,
lo voy a hacer en naranja,
esto es "-6t" más "g" es igual a 6, ahora, piensa que está pasando cuando sumamos las dos ecuaciones,
básicamente estoy agregando lo mismo
a ambos lados de la ecuación de arriba
o puedes verlo como si estuviéramos agregando lo mismo a ambos términos de la ecuación de abajo,
ya que la otra ecuación es una igualdad,
"-6t" más "g" es igual a 6,
así es que si agrego 6 del lado derecho,
estoy agregando la misma cantidad del lado izquierdo,
por eso lo podemos hacer,
sumemos las dos ecuaciones.
Del lado izquierdo estos términos se cancelan,
para eso multiplicamos 2 por "3t"
para que se cancelaran "6t" y "-6t" y nos queda
"8g" más "g" = "9g" que es igual a 12 más 6 = 18,
ahora dividiendo entre 9 ambos lados de la ecuación,
9 entre 9 se cancela y nos queda "g" igual a 2,
ya hemos encontrado el valor de "g",
podemos sustituir arriba para encontrar el valor de "t"
en cualquiera de estas dos ecuaciones,
usemos la segunda ecuación,
tenemos que "-6t" más "g",
acabamos de encontrar el valor de "g" menos "6t" más 2,
esto es igual a 6.
Ahora, voy a restar 2 a ambos lados de la ecuación, resto 2 del lado izquierdo y 2 del lado derecho
y nos resulta, 2 más -2 se cancela
y nos queda tan solo "-6t" que es igual a 6 menos 2,
que es igual a 4, dividimos ahora entre -6,
dividiendo entre -6 ambos lados,
del lado izquierdo se cancelan estos
términos y nos da "t" igual a -4/6
ó lo que es lo mismo -2/3
y ya hemos concluido.
Ya encontramos los valores de "t" y "g"
que cumplen con las dos ecuaciones,
solo vimos que cumplen la de abajo,
para tener la certeza de que cumplen la de arriba,
vamos a sustituir estos valores en la ecuación de arriba, esto es 3 por -2/3, el valor de "t"
más 4  por el valor de "g"...
más 4 por 2, ahora, esto es -2,
estos 3 se cancelan,
más 4 por 2 es 8, -2 más 8 es igual a 6...
Sí, es el valor que está planteando la ecuación,
así es que estos dos valores
definitivamente
cumplen con las dos ecuaciones.